hey what up there friends
um so this video is going to be kind of
a radical experiment for
me um for those of you who don't know me
my name is Drex I usually make videos
about po spinning and flow arts and uh
occasionally dip my toes
into also talking about business and
culture and things like that to varying
degrees of
success and been having kind of a rough
time uh the past few weeks
um be I'll be honest with you I've had a
a rough few months um there's been kind
of a lot going on in my life and
um hasn't helped that uh I live in
Washington DC and uh fall hit us couple
weeks ago like like we owed it money
um and I've really been struggling to
get work done
and struggling with very very early
onset of seasonal defective
disorder
um I normally get that a little bit
later on in the fall it hit me pretty
early this year and it's really been a
challenge for me to kind
of
navigate things that I think are going
to help like uh checking in with myself
and being like okay what do you need
right now kid um traditionally I'm not
very good at that it's it's a working
progress some of the things that I've
been doing including you
know cooking meals for myself that make
me happy um both stuff that I know is a
home run and stuff that is still a work
in progress which spoilers those recipes
are still work in progress but also too
um getting out and doing physical
activity hiking going to the museums
here in DC going and visiting the
dinosaurs always makes me really
happy but also too getting out and
flowing because moving my body doing
dance and flow and working through
whatever emotions I have pent up is also
something that I found is really
helpful now one of those things that's
been getting me down lately is just kind
of feeling a little directionless and
like every every possible way I see
forward for myself seems to
uh it seems like the ideas that in my I
have in my head are just not good enough
like uh and I had a an interesting
discussion with a good friend yesterday
where I was talking about this and
um comparing myself unfavorably to some
other people that um I have seen in the
flow Arts social media media space
online and um talking about feeling like
I need to show up and do something just
absolutely Dynamite to compete
and my friend was very kind and took me
aside and was just like look what
they're doing isn't perfect and what you
do isn't perfect
either and that's okay
and you know what matters is less that
what you show up with is perfect then it
does you know whether it is still good
enough for the people that are that are
showing up and watching what you're
doing so right now I'm trying out an
experiment in radical
imperfection um
I am not going to do any edits on this
video
um no cuts no nothing
I'm just going to kind of sit with where
I am and share it with you
all um and invite you to come out and uh
watch me flow because I need a little
bit of movement in my day
um I really love coming out and flowing
when I'm in my Fields because it helps
me process my Fields this is one of the
biggest reasons I pivoted into dance is
um
um it's something that helps me kind of
work through whatever is going on in my
head it gives me uh it gives me space to
be able to recognize what I'm feeling
process it and be able to move on so I'm
going to I'm going to share that with
you all today um we're in my favorite
spot this is uh in Jessup Blair park
across the street from where I live I
have my
little Bluetooth speaker right here I'm
going to turn this on and um going to
turn on my Apple music suggested
playlist and we will see what it comes
up with for me today I have no way of
knowing what that's going to be and I'm
just going to flow out for you uh a
couple
songs just give my whole body a chance
to breathe and
um yeah see if uh see if sharing that
with all of you is uh something that
makes me feel deep uncomfortable or
something that uh something that works
out for me so step
one step two I actually brought out two
sets of poi here I've got my sock boy
and I've got my uh flow mojas and I
think I'm feeling the sock poy today um
this is the first time we've really
gotten sun in several days um and I
think that these are going to show up
nice and bright on camera so that'll be
nice
um
yeah I know that the lighting here is
not ideal uh what can I say uh part of
part of what I like about this spot is
uh that it's really easy to be out um
and have the Sun at my back so it's not
in it's not completely in my eyes the
whole
time
and we've
got music what is it going to
be cool I'm here for
[Music]
it do think I needed to be louder
though
[Music]
[Applause]
getting I often find myself here
thinking about the bird the Bo and pass
L flew away all started sinking and it's
czy here without you I used to think
this all was our we stay up late debate
on how we find you say it's all up been
St some night I Ru the world with bars
and pretty girls but most nights I stay
straight and think about my
mom oh God I miss you so
much
[Music]
and there are people on street they're
coming up to me and they're telling me
that they like what I do now and so I
tried my best when I took the right back
up back and you on you're right here I
do I miss
[Music]
you I feel like I have it all back
before I lost it
all now I just wait for you to talk to
me why you even look at me
baby and i' been saying that
you you're always holding on
St I think they better from
Far cuz no one
oh he going to save
us W and
[Music]
me well I am fading in the
dark so don't you ever kiss me don't you
wish on me why can't you see that no
one's going to save
us ooh
CL on
[Music]
girl
I
[Music]
I I just need to help
you I close my eyes and think about
tomorrow
it never came
to it came
to it never
came oh
[Music]
you you always
long you always on me
stars
cuz
he going to
save oh and
you you're
[Music]
always I think they're better from
afar because no
one he going to save
us
oh
me why
you so don't you ever kiss me don't you
wish on me why can't you see
the going to save
us going to save us going to sa
[Music]
me
let me let me let
we are we are you are you are you
[Music]
are
on always holding
on you're always holding
[Music]
oning you're always holding
on
you're
[Music]
I still to be love without in pleas help
me help
me and crave to have childish PE while
we me me like rolling and my
S
taking
forever I've try to con with her but now
she's
[Music]
goodone is a
CH what kind of affection is making
Mar
[Music]
with string
love lost
FL Miss
Mar
ah we
pain won't
SL I
[Music]
to
taking try to with her but now she's
[Music]
gone will kind of
perfection
making they see my
heart they keep
away they sh my
[Music]
away I see my
heart
they keep
away they sh my
heart keep
[Music]
away
taking try to with her but now
she's this is ch
what kind
of
[Music]
making so of course my attempt to just
do a single video no edits and no cuts
um I forgot to clear off the memory card
so whoops I guess we'll just chalk that
up to another part of this experiment in
imperfection uh thanks for bearing with
me there um this did help it felt good
to let loose a little bit I definitely
have some feelings of anxiety around
putting something like this out to the
general public because of course it
feels very loose and unfinished but I
think this will be good for
me um yeah if uh you'd like to support
me or the channel there's a few
different ways you can do that uh I have
a patreon um also uh I have a new round
of poy dance classes that is starting up
uh on Tuesday October 3rd there's still
plenty of room in that class you can
register at crowdcast doio drexfactor
poy I'll include a link down in the
description um I I would really
appreciate if more people could show up
to those classes cuz uh they it's a nice
little Community around it and um I
definitely it helps me out a
lot um big thanks to the Friends of the
channel uh dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
light toys spinballs and Ultra for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible um you can learn more
about them down in the description I've
got links to them all uh special thanks
to Becca
beonin
um the non- bus friend of the channel I
appreciate you thanks for supporting me
and of course uh thanks to my flow
patrons over on patreon uh I am their
their names are uh displayed on screen
right now with me here um thank you for
watching uh uh hope you got something
out of this and if you want to check out
some more videos that I've made there
will be links on screen to do that or uh
a link down in the description so
um yeah appreciate you all watching take
care I'm hoping the fog lifts soon for
me cuz it is uh it's not fun but getting
out and flowing did help thanks for
joining me bye